well bears are beginning their defense
of their NFC North championship even
though it didn't end well in the
postseason
we both have them going to the play yes
it's time to unveil our NFC picks and we
both have the Bears as the three seed in
the NFC quit looking off my homework I
had my pics done Thursday I published
them Tuesday morning you did your Sunday
you published them yesterday afternoon
on your pot yeah actually yesterday
morning to five out of six of the same
team together again yeah we've got that
we both have the Eagles Panthers Bears
Seahawks and Cowboys going to playoffs
we only differ on the Vikings and the
Saints I've got Minnesota's the five
seed you've got the Saints stealing the
six seed other than that we're identical
and a little seeding difference I've got
the Seahawks at 2:00 and the Panthers at
4:00 you've got the Panthers at to the
Seahawks at 4:00 but other than that we
we've got a pretty identity I mean it's
10 out of 12 playoff teams think about
there's 32 teams the NFL we have 10 out
of the same 12 playoff that means we're
working too much together texting too
much together and we've basically
flushed out our thoughts together on air
throughout the offseason how we feel
about these football teams and yeah I
feel good about it I mean it was one of
those things I do I think the Eagles are
gonna be the best team in the NFC I
certainly do you know one of my big
reasons with them is you know first six
games that I do think they're gonna get
off to a good start really their first
six games are against all inferior
football teams another reason I take
them because some of their biggest games
are at home whether it's the Patriots
the Seahawks the Bears and then at the
end of the season the Cowboys got to go
to Philadelphia it was really well put
me over the top to go okay I'm gonna
make Philly my number one seed the
Panthers I think are probably the one
that's gonna surprise the most that's
approximating you have them as the two
yeah right I know I just I look at the
Panthers is gone ooh it's the best
talent I've seen around Cam Newton as
far as weapons the offensive line has
been solidified it's big it's
overpowering I like that we've seen
what's how special Christian McCaffrey
is defense'll I have one issue with the
Carolina Panthers they got great size on
the front seven linebackers good I like
Bradbury and Dante Jackson a corner pass
rushers that's the only thing we need to
see and that's why they drafted Brian
burns and
fifteen or sixteen in the NFL Draft they
just need a guy to be a little bit more
disruptive in that department but yeah
I'm picking this to be one of those
years like a 2015 where I think the
Panthers are very dangerous I think we
both assume that the Eagles will have
Carson Wentz most of the year yeah
they're not the number one seed now look
they were the number one seed two years
ago they lost him in December and they
were the underdog in every playoff game
that they would go on to win but you are
assuming both Wentz and Cam Newton will
stay healthy yes I just I don't know
what to think anymore I know it's a it's
scary it does scare me we saw him for a
glimpse in the playoffs are in the
preseason rather than he got hurt right
well he's in a walking boot after the
game against the page yeah III get that
and you know it is the preseason guys
and teams are extra careful I again this
is a guy you know traditionally through
his career who's not been banged up a
lot it's been a lot of Nicks and nax and
always on the injury before but he plays
and I don't think that'll be anything
different this year and he's talked
about maybe adjusting the style applied
just a little bit so we'll see where
that goes but yes I'm very bullish on
the Panthers in general we both of the
Bears is number three right so that's
kind of cool I mean the Bears are one of
the best rosters in football my logic
there may be some Bears fans that aren't
happy that they're at number three well
I get that you know I did I mean really
I try to do this as unbeknown into it I
want know the Bears are gonna be a first
round by type of team for me but I think
we both agree the NFC North is gonna be
better I mean all three other teams
right on we don't have the Packers I
think they're gonna be in the
conversation the Lions I think will be
in the conversation I'm with you with
the bikes I think we'll put me over the
top with like the Bears and kind of
scaring me off there is their first five
week first five weeks are very good as
far as inferior competition but then
they go through some stretches their
last four weeks they got to play Rogers
and mahomes again that week seven eight
and nine they just go through some
stretches in the middle and the end of
their season where I go oh I wonder if
they'll survive it that's kind of where
I kind of bump them down a spot you are
amazingly old-school yes I can I do this
for a second
I feel like I'm in high school again
he's got a notebook he's got a page got
you it's like you took notes in his I
did I told you I sat down Sunday and I
did that I've see brackets and I know I
just got to write it out though because
if I did I worry about by typing and now
I don't have to worry about my typing I
just write and think about my brain I
would worry about my typing - if I had
gigantic hands yes I'm a normal human
sized kid right the let's fast forward
to the playoffs yeah you've got the
Cowboys going to Seattle and winning in
the wild-card round
I didn't Jeff Tony Romo that was how his
career started with that that fumbled
snap on the field goal that would have
won the game okay that's a lot of faith
in the Cowboys I know up there and win
it is I kind of look at it it is I do
think they're they're a team that
matches up well with the Seattle
Seahawks they're both very similar right
where it's about oh this is what we do
we do it really well and we're just
gonna out physical you and out hustle
and our speed on the field is gonna
bother you and I just think the Cowboys
are the slightly better version of that
to where yes
they beat they they they beat the
Seahawks on the road and though in a
wild card just as surprising you get the
Saints coming here to Chicago and beat
in the Bears you got both road teams in
the wild-card I have the Saints because
I got them in they have the I think one
of the toughest eight weeks the first
eight weeks of the season when you look
at the Saints I mean it's brutal
okay when you really break it down I'm
just gonna roll off some nated some
teams here but it's Texans Rams Seahawk
Cowboys bucks okay
Jaguars bears that's their first seven
games of the year
man that is brutal so I do think the
Saints I can finish in them getting off
to a slow start ending the season on a
hot note and taking that hot note into
Chicago and upsetting the Bears I don't
think that the Saints are a better
football team but I drew brees Sean
Payton everything like that I think in a
clutch situation in one game playoff
scenario I'm gonna take them to win it
we both have disrespected the defending
NFC champion I know we have neither of
us have I know I was waiting for you to
bring it up I offset all yes I
ultimately if you're not getting better
you're staying the same and I feel like
that would the Rams okay right that's
what I know
to say if you're staying the same you're
getting worse is what I meant to say
really but okay
they got Eric Weddle Clay Matthews good
players certainly not but what did I
rather have in Dhamma consumer LaMarcus
Joyner yes Todd Gurley issue Andrew
Whitworth a year older often the line
was not that great to begin with their
best offensive lineman Roger self of
Saffold leaves in free agency so plus
the I'm just playing the gut that
there's new teams in the playoffs every
year and the Rams and the Super Bowl
hangover it's a real thing say what you
want but the losing team Super Bowl
hanger if you're not named the Patriots
has had issues bouncing back the next
year three points scored in the Super
Bowl I don't care what you say I don't
care what you do you can't shake that
quickly right and I know they're gonna
be upset I think Peters argument
yesterday was well they're gonna they're
gonna come out and they're gonna go
they're gonna be more decisive and
they're gonna go for the jugular and
they you can say all that yeah but can
you do all that and have the Patriots
provided the rest of the NFL with the
code-cracking of the rams off I think
it's a legit question we got to see it
we got to see if McVeigh is gonna add
new things to the offense too you know
yeah bring back the power under his side
you're right I think Vic Fangio the
Patriots all gave a little bit of a
blueprint of how to slow down the
McVeigh and the Rams offense to a degree
and I am interested to see what McVeigh
does this year differently and how he
kind of reinvents himself all right
ultimately we both have the eagles
winning the conference championship I
have them beating the Seahawks at home
Chris has them beating the Panthers at
home and you have ultimate faith in the
Eagles to win and all the Eagles over
the Chiefs I mean Andy Reed versus old
team I mean isn't it isn't it hard to
set those aside it is I do that is the
hardest thing about this right it's just
taking like the biased away oh okay
gosh I'm rooting for this team like I'm
rooting for the 49ers and my buddy Kyle
Shanahan oh yes well that's how I'm out
there right now I'm rooting for him and
I wanted to put him in the playoffs so I
said damn I think I'm just putting them
in the playoffs cuz I wanted
happen I want my buddy to get it I don't
know if I realistically think about that
think that football wise and a little
bit like we couldn't stamp our name to
Jacoby burr set and the Colts forget in
the playoffs feel the same way with the
49ers
I just can't stamp my approval of Oh
Jimmy Garoppolo things are gonna be
great and they're gonna go to the
playoffs I can't do it yet one of those
things I kind of see it to believe it
but wasn't the better story be the
Chiefs beat the Eagles and Andy Reid
finally getting a superb at what but I'm
staying true to my belief I think the
Eagles are the better football team I
think they match up well with the Chiefs
in general I mean I also I mean I had
Chiefs Jaguars and I mean that could
have been that could have been when
source polls in the Super Bowl if the
jaguars ended up to play the Eagles but
either way I think the Eagles are the
team this year I mean I see the Patriots
and egos getting together again and the
Patriots get their revenge the revenge
yeah yeah be a good one what what what
ultimately
okay you got Eagles over the Seahawks in
the NFC Championship game you just don't
think Seattle because I know you love Co
you don't think they can go across the
country and beat Eagles and that and
their territory Carson Wentz's healthy
yeah it's getting very difficult to do
now
now if whence gets injured in December
again and that throws it all into flux
and if they hold on at home in the
divisional round maybe Josh McCown won't
be able to handle the Seattle oh yes
Hawks look I already thought they were
gonna be special yeah a for Jadeveon
Clowney and I don't know that clowny
dramatically makes them better but he
does make them better definitely does
and this is a team I was on radio last
night KJR one of the affiliates that
plays our show live out there in Seattle
like why why do people continue to
disrespect Pete Carroll and Russell
Wilson and not recognize what they've
been able to do it's like every year
like what we don't care about that
Wilson's not that he's just a running
quarterback yeah they still are a team
that takes full advantage of home-field
advantage yeah and which was why it's
called home-field advantage should take
advantage of it yeah and and Pete
Carroll does the best with the roster
that he has knows how to create that air
of competition and he you know then the
offensive line is better than it's ever
been during his
time now I I think there's a chance they
will be the one seat I I don't think
it's crazy I'm with you I mean it's one
of those things again where I mean I'm
with you with the Seahawks in general
but it's just because they don't have
household names yet I think the public
doesn't want to get this not here they
become House exactly right I swear I
feel the - I mean yeah we didn't think
they were gonna get in the playoffs in
2018 we all went aw the Seahawks they're
in a rebuilding it oh this Justin Pete
Carroll and John Schneider know too how
to evaluate and build a roster they knew
they had something last year and that
they had guys why they could let Richard
Sherman and Earl Thomas and everybody
else go or they weren't really about
replacing them or giving them contracts
because they knew they had guys coming
up the ranks that were pretty damn good
football players - they've done it
before they're doing it again the thing
Russell Wilson told me last year after
they beat the Lions at a time when we
really weren't sure which way it was
gonna break for either team last year
right he said it feels like 2012 all
over again which makes this 2013 yeah
which is the year they ran roughshod
over the confident ah
that's a no they won the Super Bowl
blowing the Broncos off the field so
don't be surprised if the Seahawks make
something happen this year and maybe
they make us both look wrong as to our
NFC champion pick the Packers yeah we
got them up but it's like you're the
ones gonna deal with Aaron Rodgers not
me well that's it hurt me I mean again
it was hurting me but I went down to it
I said man I gotta see this little euler
offense and everything worked before I
can put it on paper and go oh yeah I
feel good about the Packers got to see
it to believe it there first
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports